another kamala staffer heading for the
hills joining the mass exodus of workers
who couldn't stand one more minute
listening to her laugh
harris's deputy chief of staff michael
fuchs
becoming the 12th aide that's how you
say it no it's not luke's
anyway the guy called it quits you can
figure out his name later which comes
amid the vp's latest train wreck of an
interview i'm making fun of her he said
that vladimir putin um should no longer
be the leader of russia
do you agree
listen i think that you you
framed the point
quite accurately and well
which is america's policy has been and
will continue to be focused on the real
issue at hand which is one
the needs of the ukrainian people which
we will continue to support
through humanitarian assistance through
security assistance but also ensuring
that there's going to be serious
consequence for vladimir putin all right
to support
anyway convalesce troubles don't end
there the veep going mask-less at an
elementary school monday of course
surrounded by masked of children the
power
versus the powerless jessica you are a
very hard worker very successful woman
everybody every young woman would want
to be like you i think that people
have a problem with kamala harris
because we all know someone like that
someone who kind of coasts and glides
unlike you someone who might have cut in
line who doesn't do the work we all know
people like that jessie i'm sorry
jessica um but they're like but it's i
think we're now seeing that she doesn't
want to do the work she doesn't want to
read the read the the prep work and so
she shows up and she sounds like you
know very she sounds like she just wants
to get through it how's that for an
analysis jessica well it was smart you
appealed to my ego so that would get me
in the mood to do some democrat bashing
um i don't really want to though we've
already talked about this i believe i
was the one actually who brought up the
fact that staffers have complained that
she isn't reading the briefing books and
that's really the cardinal sin of how
you treat your staff they invest hours
and hours and hours of their time and
they've built decades of experience so
that they can make you smarter about
these reading the packets yes
who needs to read the packets one thing
i will say about the turnover and
obviously that's high turnover and you
haven't seen the same levels leaving the
president's office but we are heading
into a midterm cycle and it is very
common for people to leave at that point
because they are traditionally people
who have worked on the campaign
they work in the white house and or in
the vp's office and then they want to go
back out there on the campaign trail
because that's their natural habitat so
that is something
that happens i heard you let out a hump
when uh we talked to when did she going
to hang out with the kids and she's not
wearing a mask and the kids are all
messed it's just crazy it's like do do
her does her staff not look at any media
how many how many politicians have to
get into this situation like stacey
abrams remember she even actually
finally apologized for it so it's not
hard like you're gonna have a
and also they have advanced teams so
it's not like it was spontaneous they're
gonna go they're like everyone's masked
and she's not all the adults are not
masked they're not you know what it goes
back to your they're not trying to help
her no they're not trying to help her
but nobody's trying to help her and also
i just don't i feel like you wouldn't be
surprised if the babylon be like if the
headline was kamala harris to leave vice
president kamala harris's office because
of a toxic work environment every day
it's almost like a joke every day like
somebody else left how many staffers are
there and usually for every politician
you will have somebody who's like a
lifer yeah like who was with you from
the beginning who was your bad guy that
became the chief of staff like who is
that person in her world who's your
choose your johnny who's your job i have
a johnny she doesn't have a johnny
people at home are trying to figure out
that out is that something on urban
dictionary
don't look up johnny it is now jessie uh
people are fleeing her like she's a
war-torn country it's not it's just not
good
and
people left trump because they were
fired right people are running away from
kamala harris and kamala actually makes
sure reed looks smart so that's an
accomplishment there she makes mistakes
with the masks in the school because
dana she doesn't have an advanced team
her entire advanced team has resigned
her entire communications team is gone
her top two speech writers are gone her
social media strategist resigned her
national security adviser resigned and
now her deputy chief of staff has
resigned
is the media gonna just say oh it's the
13th staffer that left it's the 14th
when are they going to write the truth
the woman can't talk and everybody hates
her same with the president he can't
talk and he's incompetent we have the
record highest gas prices record high
inflation record high border crossers
and no one's talking about this we're
acting like this is a normal presidency
this is the worst presidency
statistically of all time and we're
acting like okay the midterms are coming
excuse me
yeah record high gas prices record high
by the way at that school masks are
optional they did release a statement
but all the kids are in them all right
you know what here's the thing we're
blaming the woman's staff
excuse me you're the vice president of
the united states you don't know if the
school you're going to if there's an
issue about kids wearing masks or not
wearing masks she doesn't need a staff
for this the bottom line is she can't
communicate with us so how could she
possibly communicate with her own staff
if she's too stupid to talk and say
anything other than
our job always has been and continues to
be that which we are going to continue
to do until we solve the issue that we
went in to solve from the beginning and
that is hang on jesse every day
every day look i've said it before this
woman is the insurance policy for joe
biden we're all praying that joe biden
has good health that he's well cared for
so this woman never becomes president
because i never want to be in a
situation where i'm praying for el sid
to come out and you know when we prop
the guy up because we don't want her as
president the woman is not smart i'm
tired of people saying we should look up
to her she's a disaster joe's a disaster
you can't possibly say they're doing
anything good you speak to any american
who has to decide whether they want to
put gas in their car or whether they
want to take a bicycle to work this is
not what americans should be have to
deal with because this guy shut down gas
pipelines in the united states and now
is going to russia and venezuela this is
un-american and that's the end of it
that's the end are you sure that's the
end of it
because we still got another 40 minutes
i was going to say you just reminded me
of a great idea that i had and if you're
a good politician you look at what gets
other politicians in trouble she should
have seen what happened with stacey
abrams and the mask in the kindergarten
said i'm not going to be stacey abrams
makes it that simple that's smart it's
not that hard how did she get there will
someone tell me
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else